สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะน้องเกรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
ครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 14
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
เมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 13
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 15
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
5 ทุ่ม
:00 น
ค่ะ
ค่ะ 5 ทุ่ม 20 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางคืน
ไปนอนค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย
เอาวีดีโอนี้จบก่อนสิ
นอนดึกๆเนี่ยไม่ดีนะครูฟ้า 5 ทุ่มเนี่ย
ดึกมากๆ
5 ทุ่มดึกมากๆหรอแล้วต้องนอนกี่โมงอ่ะ
ผู้หญิง
เอานี้
นอนซะ
ถ้า 4 ทุ่ม
ครูฟ้าต้องนอนแล้ว
3 ทุ่มครึ่ง
ก็โอเคนอนได้แต่ถ้าเลย 4 ทุ่ม 4 ทุ่ม
ครึ่ง
มันดึกเกินไปอะไรคะ
ทำไม
ไม่อยากโกน 23:30 นโอเคไหม
โอเค
ไม่โอเคไม่โอเค
มีคำถามเยอะจังเลยนะคะเอ้าก็นอนดึกๆเนี่ย
มันอันตรายนะครูฟ้า
นอนดึกๆมันอันตราย
ใช่ไหม
มันไม่ดีกับร่างกายของครูฟ้าหัวใจครูฟ้า
สมอง
มีครูฟ้าใช่ไหมเนี่ยสมอง
ร่างกายมันไม่ดีกับร่างกายนอนดึกบ่อยๆทุก
วันทุกวันๆเนี่ยหัวใจไม่โอเคนะมันอันตราย
กับหัวใจ
อันตรายครูฟ้าไม่กลัว
อะไรก็อันตราย
กับหัวใจนะครูฟ้าจะเป็นหัวใจแล้วก็
ตายเลยนะครูฟ้าอยากตายแล้วเหรอคะ
ไม่กลัว
ชอบน้อย
ไม่ได้ครูฟ้ามันอันตรายกับหัวใจของครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงต้องมีรูปนี้ไว้ที่บ้านครูฟ้าแล้ว
ล่ะค่ะเวลาเห็นรูปนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าจะได้
เข้าใจว่าโอ๊ยนอนดึกอันตรายไม่ดีกับร่าง
กายไม่ดีกับ
หัวใจ
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่กลัวอันตรายหรอกค่ะผู้หญิงกูฟังไม่
กลัวเหรอคะอันตรายอาจทำให้ครูฟัดตายได้นะ
จริงหรอตายเลยหรอ
อ้าวถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีรถใช่ไหมมีรถ
แล้วครูฟ้าขับรถความเร็ว 200 กมต่อ
ชั่วโมงอย่างนี้
อันตรายใช่ไหมครูฟ้าก็อาจจะตายได้ไง
ขับรถเร็วอันตราย
อะไรคะ
พี่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยเขาขับรถเร็วไหมคะ
ขับรถ
80 เท่านั้น
ต่อชั่วโมงไม่อันตราย
ขับรถเนี่ย
ขับรถเนี่ยก็กรุงเทพฯเนี่ย 20 กิโลเมตร
ต่อชั่วโมงค่ะ
ทำไมขับรถช้ามากคะ
อ้าวนี่ไงเพราะว่ากรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีถนนใช่
ไหมคะแล้วก็มีรถๆๆ
ๆ
เยอะๆค่ะ
ขับเร็วไม่ได้
รถเยอะจังเลยค่ะ
ตายแต่ถ้ามอเตอร์ไซค์
ใช่ไหมอันนี้มอเตอร์ไซค์นะคะนักเรียน
มอเตอร์ไซค์ครูฟ้าชอบขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่
ไหมไม่ใช่ชอบกิน
ชอบนั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์มีผู้ชายแล้วก็เป็นคน
ขับแล้วก็ครูฟ้านี่โซฟา
มอเตอร์ไซค์แท็กซี่ไงครูฟ้าชอบนั่ง
มอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่ไหม
นักเรียนอาจจะคิดว่าอุ๊ยนั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์
ที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ย
อันตราย
ครูฟ้าคิดว่านั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์ที่ประเทศไทย
เนี่ยอันตรายไหมคะ
ทำไมคิดนานจัง
เราก็ครูฟ้าชอบนั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์ที่ประเทศ
ไทย
ก็เลยคิดใช่ไหมว่าอันตรายไม่อันตราย
อันตรายไม่อันตราย
แต่ว่านั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์ที่ประเทศไทยนะนัก
เรียนอันตรายค่ะ
ทำไมคะทำไมครูฟ้าคิดว่าอันตราย
เนี่ยขับขี่เร็ว
มอเตอร์ไซค์ที่ไทยเร็วมากนะคะนักเรียน
วินดีเซล
ใช่แล้วถ้ารถติดใช่ไหมมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ย
เวลาครูฟ้านั่งเนี่ยขาของครูฟ้าก็อาจจะ
โดนรถที่ขับอยู่ก็ได้นะเห็นไหมอันตรายนะ
ไม่โอเคนะมอเตอร์ไซค์ในกรุงเทพฯ
ถ้านักเรียนมาก็ต้องดูดีๆนะคะเพราะว่า
มอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยอันตรายแล้วถ้าเอามาไหนๆ
ก็มอเตอร์ไซค์แล้วแล้วนี่ประเทศไทยไหมคะ
จะดูหน้าตาก็เด็กคนไทยไหมแล้วถ้านั่ง
มอเตอร์ไซค์อันนี้เป็นคนขี่ใช่ไหมผู้ชาย
เนี่ยเป็นคนขี่แล้วก็มีคนซ้อนเนี่ย
อะไรเนี่ย
อันไหนคะ
คุณพ่อเนี่ยก็เลยเอาเก้าอี้มาวางแล้วก็
ให้น้องนั่งเห็นไหม
5 คน
รถมันแพงไงครูฟ้ารถ
1 ล้าน
1 ล้านบาทมอเตอร์ไซค์ 1 คันเนี่ย 10,000
บาทหรือเปล่า
แล้วถ้ามอเตอร์ไซค์ 1 คันแล้วก็ซ้อน 1  2
3  4 ซ้อนสี่แบบนี้อันตรายไหมคะครูฟ้า
คิดว่าอันตรายไหม
ที่สุด
มอเตอร์ไซค์โซน 4 ไม่ได้
ครูฟ้าเคยไหมอ่ะ
นักเรียน
ตอนครูฟ้าครูฟ้า
ก็จะเป็นคนอันนี้คือฟ้าใช่ไหม
แล้วก็มีเพื่อน
แล้วก็มีเพื่อนครูฟ้า
4 คน
มีเก้าอี้แบบนี้ไหม
ไม่มีจริงๆ
เห็นมั้ย
เอ่อสอนสิแล้วตอนครูฟ้าขี่ครูฟ้าใส่หมวก
กันน็อคไหมคะเนี่ยหมวกกันน็อค
หมวกกันน็อคหมวกกันน็อค
profi ฟ้าไม่ได้ใส่หมวกกันน็อค
ก็เป็น Double อันตรายเลยนะคะขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ซ้อนสี่แล้วก็ไม่ใส่หมวกกัน
น็อคอันตรายคูณสองมากๆ
อันตรายคือศพ
นักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนะคะนักเรียนจะเห็น
แบบรูปนี้เนี่ยมากๆแต่ไม่ใช่ที่กรุงเทพฯ
นะ
กรุงเทพฯอาจจะไม่ค่อยมีนะ
กรุงเทพฯแต่ถ้าไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯแบบพัทยา
เชียงใหม่ภูเก็ตเยอะค่ะแบบนี้ยิ่งช่วย
เฉพาะเด็กๆนะคะแต่อันตรายเนาะ
แต่ถ้าไม่ได้ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ล่ะ
ขับรถ
ถ้าคุณพ่อขับรถแล้วก็ให้ลูกนั่งตักคุณพ่อ
แล้วก็ขับรถไปด้วยแบบนี้อันตรายไหมเพราะ
ว่าอันนี้ไม่ใช่มอเตอร์ไซค์
ไม่อันตราย
อันตรายค่ะ
อ้าวทำไมล่ะคะอันนี้ไม่ใช่มอเตอร์ไซค์นะ
เอ้าถ้าขับรถแล้วอยู่ๆรถชน
มันก็จะมี airbag ใช่ไหม
เด็กก็ตายสิ
อ้าว
ทำไมอ่ะก็ airbag มันช่วยให้เราเนี่ยไม่
ตายไม่ใช่หรอ
ไม่ค่ะเด็กตัวเล็กๆใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนเป็น
Baby อ่ะ
โดนแอร์แบ็คเข้าไปเพราะว่าน่าจะไม่โอเคนะ
แล้วนั่งแบบนี้ก็น่าจะไม่โอเคด้วย
เพราะว่า airbag มันๆๆ
น่าจะตาย
ก่อน
หรือถ้ารถไม่ชนถ้าขับไปขับไปอาจจะขับความ
เร็ว 80 กมต่อชั่วโมงแต่มันจะมีรถรถอ่า
อันนี้สมมุติว่าเป็นรถของคนนี้นะคะแล้วก็
ข้างหน้าเนี่ยมีรถถ้ารถคันเนี้ยเบรกอยู่
ดีๆแบบเบรกอ่ะ
รถของคุณพ่อก็จะเบรคใช่ไหมคะหรือคันหน้า
เนี่ยกำลังขับกำลังขับแล้วอยู่ดีๆคันข้าง
หน้าเนี่ยเบรคเหยียบเบรคคุณพ่อก็ต้องเบรก
มันก็จะแบบหน้าอย่างนี้น้องนี่อาจจะลอย
ได้เลยนะ
ใช่น่ากลัวนะคะ
อันนี้อันตราย
มากกว่ามอเตอร์ไซค์อีกนะคะอันตรายมากๆ
นักเรียนอาจจะคิดว่าอันตรายเท่ากันนะ
ประเทศไทยแบบนี้ก็มีเยอะเหมือนกันนะบาง
ครั้งเนี่ยก็เห็นนะคะอันนี้ก็อันตรายเนาะ
อันนี้
เปลี่ยน topic บ้างไม่ขับรถไม่ขี่รถแล้ว
ยันมาที่การกิน
คือกินเนี่ยไม่อันตรายนะคะนักเรียนกิน
เยอะๆก็อาจจะอันตรายถ้ามีไขมัน
คอเลสเตอรอลแต่อันนี้เนี่ยไม่เกี่ยวกับไข
มันคอเลสเตอรอลอะไรนะคะแต่ว่าเวลาที่กิน
นักเรียนเห็นไหมเนี่ยมันจะมีไม้
แล้วไม้เนี่ยมันจะมีตรงนี้ที่แหลมๆเวลา
ที่เรากินอะไรที่เสียบไม้แล้วก็กินแบบนี้
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าอันตรายไหมคะเนี่ยกินแบบที่
เขากินอยู่เนี่ย
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าชัวร์
ทำไมอ่ะนักเรียนบอกมาประเทศไทยเห็นคนไทย
เนี่ยกินอาจจะเป็นลูกชิ้นไหมอันนี้น่าจะ
เป็นลูกชิ้นไหมเนี่ยนักเรียนเนี่ยลูกชิ้น
ลูกชิ้นปิ้งเสียบไม้เห็นคนไทยเนี่ยกินมาก
ๆ
ทำไมครูฟ้าคิดอันตราย
อันตรายสิคะเพราะว่าไม้เนี่ยนักเรียนซูม
ดูค่ะซูมสูง
ไม้เนี่ยนะคะ
โอเค
แหลม
ใช่มันแหลม
แล้วถ้ามัน
มันทิ่มเราหรอ
จริงๆอ่ะ
เรากินน่ะไม่ค่อยเท่าไหร่นะแต่ถ้าข้าง
หลังเนี่ยมีคน
เนี่ยกำลังเดินมาแล้วชน
ชนแขนของเราแขนเนี้ยค่ะนักเรียนไอ้ไม้
แหลมๆเนี่ยกูอันตรายมากเลยนะอันนี้
ซุปเปอร์อันตรายเลยนะคะนักเรียนถ้านัก
เรียนมาประเทศไทยเนี่ยจะกินแบบนี้ดูดีๆนะ
คะว่าข้างหลังเราเนี่ยไม่มีคนเดินมาคนเรา
กำลังอยู่อย่างนี้ใช่ไหมถ้าเขาชน
มันทิ่มปากของเราเลยนะคะ
อืมน่ากลัวนะคะเห็นไหมไม่โอเค
อันนี้ก็อันตรายนะ
อันตรายค่ะนักเรียนเนี่ยมาไทยแล้วนัก
เรียนกินบาร์บีคิวหรือว่าอะไรแบบนี้นัก
เรียนต้องดูเช็คดีๆนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วถ้าเอาเข้าปากไปเลยแบบนี้อันไหน
อันตรายมากกว่ากันคะครูฟ้า
[เพลง]
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมเขาแบบนี้อ่าส่วนผู้ชายคนนี้
เนี่ยเขากินแบบนี้เลยลูกชิ้นเหมือนกันนี่
เป็นไส้กรอกนะคะ
[เพลง]
ทำไมอ่ะคะทำไมครูฟ้าคิดว่ากินแบบนี้
อันตรายมากกว่าแล้วก็นี่ไงไม้เนี่ยเห็น
มั้ยเข้าไปข้างใน
มันอยู่ในป่าของเราแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะใช่
อันตรายมากกว่า
เพราะว่าจริงๆเวลาเวลาเรากินลูกชิ้นปิ้ง
หรือว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกินหมูปิ้งใช่ไหม
หมูปิ้งเนี่ยมันจะมีไม้แบบนี้ค่ะ
แล้วไม้เนี่ยมันก็จะแหลมๆอย่างนี้แหละ
เนาะแหลมๆแบบนี้
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยเวลาเรากินใช่ไหมเราก็จะ
เอาไม้เนี่ยด้านที่แหลมๆแบบนี้เข้าไปใน
ป่าใช่ไหมคะคุณพ่อเนาะคุณพ่อคุณแม่เนี่ย
ก็จะบอกว่าให้กินแบบนี้
ทั้งข้าง
อันตรายอันตรายน้อยกว่าไงน้อยกว่า
อันตรายเหมือนกันนะคะนักเรียน
คนอันตรายเหมือนกัน
ยิ้มปากของเราได้นะเวลากินต้องดูดีๆนะคะ
อ่ะ
อันนี้คืออะไรคะครูฟ้ารู้ไหมคะครูฟ้าน่า
จะชอบ
ก้างปลา
ใช่มั้ยอันนี้คือก้างปลาเพราะว่าเนื้อปลา
อยู่ที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะเราเนี่ยคือคนไทยอ่ะ
ค่ะเวลาเราซื้อปลามาเราเนี่ยเป็นคนเราก็
จะกินเนื้อปลาแต่ที่บ้านเนี่ยบางครั้ง
เนี่ยเรามีแมวไม่เหมือนครูฟ้าเนี่ยเขามี
แมว
คนไทยเนี่ยจะให้แมวเนี่ยกินก้างปลาคนไทย
บอกว่าแมวเนี่ยชอบกินปลาแต่เนื้อเนี่ย
กิน
ส่วนกลางปลาหัวปลาเนี่ยให้แมวกิน
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าให้แมวเนี่ยกินก้างปลา
อันตรายไหมสำหรับแมวนะอันตรายกับแมวไหม
ครูฟ้าเลี้ยงแมวไง
ให้แมว
กินก้างปลา
ทำไมอ่ะตั้งแต่เด็กๆที่บ้านครูหญิงมีแมว
แมวก็กินก้างปลานะ
มันแหลมมันแหลม
แมวกินก้างปลา
ก้างปลา
ก็จะอยู่ในคอของแมว
ก็เหมือนเราใช่ไหมคะรู้หญิงครูฟ้าเนี่ย
กินก้างปลาไม่ได้อันตรายแมว
แมวเนี่ย
ก็กินไม่ได้เหมือนกันอันตราย
มากนะคะแมวตายได้นะคะ
ตายได้เลย
นะคะครูฟ้าอาจจะคิดถึงประเทศไทยแล้วตอน
นี้เพราะว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยเดือนเมษายนประเทศ
ไทยมีทุเรียนมากๆทุเรียนๆ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกลิ่นทุเรียนแต่
กินกินทั้งลูกเนี่ยก็อันตรายอยู่นะคน
เดียวทั้งลูกเนี่ยมันแหลมค่ะนักเรียนเห็น
ไหมคะ
เหมือนกัน
ครูฟ้าแหลมเหมือนก้างปลาใช่ไหมแหลมเหมือน
ไม้เสียบลูกชิ้นแต่เราไม่กินไงเรากิน
เนื้อทุเรียนอะไรคะเนี่ยอ๋อขอโทษค่ะ
ลูกผู้หญิงไม่โอเคนะคะเรากินเนื้อทุเรียน
ใช่ไหมคะถ้าเรากินทุเรียนกับน้ำอัดลม
โค้กเป๊ปซี่สไปรท์เซเว่นอัพกินทุเรียน
แล้วก็ดื่มน้ำอัดลมครูฟ้าคิดว่าอันตราย
ไหมคะ
ไม่อันตรายค่ะ
จริงๆไม่อันตรายนะ
อ้าว
คือถ้าครูฟ้ากินทุเรียนมากๆแล้วดื่มน้ำ
อัดลมก็อาจจะไม่ไม่สบายนิดหน่อยแต่ถ้าครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยหัวใจหัวใจไม่ดีมันอาจจะมีปัญหา
หัวใจไม่โอเคแล้วกินทุเรียนกินทุเรียนกิน
ทุเรียนแล้วก็ดื่มน้ำอัดลมเนี่ยอันตราย
ค่ะคุณอาจจะช็อคแล้วก็ตายได้เพราะว่าน้ำ
ตาลมันเยอะไงมันหวานมันทำให้หัวใจเราเต้น
ๆๆๆๆเร็วนะคะแต่ถ้าครูหญิงกับฟ้าอย่างนี้
หัวใจโอเคก็ไม่อันตรายนะคะนั่นแหละค่ะ
แล้วนักเรียนคิดว่าอะไรอันตรายบ้างก็
comment บอกเราได้เนาะส่วนวีดีโอนี้คุณ
หญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย